خلاصه ما جاء به عامر وتامر وسلام الى همم
اللواء فايز الدويري الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي الذي كان يتابع معنا ما
نقلوه لنا ما الذي يمكن قوله عن هذه
المرحله اللواء فايز من الحرب
ات الميدانيه بعد بعد خساره خارجه
ودخول فصل الشتاء
وتعثر العمليات البريه الرئيسيه على
المستوى العمليات والحشارها فيها جمال
محدوده على المستوى التكتيكي من الجانب
الروسي او الجانب الاخراني وتحديدا في
باقمت وبعض المناطق هنا همم
بدات التغير في اليه اداره المعركه فبدا
الاعتماد على القصف الصاروقي
والحديث عن القصف الصاروخي هو حتى سابق
على مرحله دخول فصل الشتاء هذا بدا تحديدا
منذ توجيه اول ضربه الى جسر كرش وكان الرد
على اعلى المستويات وحتى الرئيس الروسي
تحدث صراحه بان من بدا في قصف المنشات هو
الجانب الاوكراني وبالتالي بدا الضغط بهذا
الاتجاه وتم تحديد اولويات الاهداف
وتمثلت في الاولوي المطلقه مهاجمه البنيه
التحتيه التي تتعلق
بامدادات الماء والكهرباء والحديث تبين من
يوم الى اخر 500 بلده 30% من الطاقه
الكهربائيه
50% من الطاقه الكهربائيه وح كان هناك همم
قراءات
احصائيه استقصائيه لمراكز عالميه مشهوره
تحدثت عن وكانت خلاصه تشير لماذا
الاستهداف لهذه البنيه التحتيه كانت نتائج
الاستطلاع
82% من سكان كيف يدعم استمرار القتال
84% من منطقه لفيف وما حولها يدعم استمرار
القتال بينما
وهذا القصف وليست المره الاولى ولكن يتم
بطائرات استراتيجيه ومن البحر الاسود هل
لهذا مؤشرات ودلالات في هذه المرحله من
الحرب يعني الان هذا يعيدنا الى تقارير
كثيره جدا بالامس وصباح هذا اليوم بعض
التقارير اشاره الى استخدام صواريخ اس 300
لمهاجمه اهداف ارضيه عش 3 هو صاروخ ضد
الجو لماذا يستخدم في دور الصواريخ ارض
ارض لنقص في المخزونات من هذه الصواريخ
الحديث عن تزوي- عن الحصول على صواريخ
فاتح 110 الايراني الحديث عن ذخائر من
كوريا الشماليه يعني ان المخزون
الاستراتيجي للصواريخ ارض ارض همم اصبح
محدودا او قارب من الخط الاحمر هنا لابد
من ايجاد وسيله اخرى وهي استخدام الطائرات
الاستراتيجيه لماذا الطائرات الاستراتيجيه
لديها القدره التقنيه على استخدام اكثر من
نوع من الصواريخ سواء صواريخ صوتيه سواء
الصواريخ الموجهه او صواريخ ما يسمى
الجنرال البربوست اي القذائف التي تسمى
بالاسقاط الحر اذا لدي القدره على ان
تستخدم ثلاثه انواع رئيسيه من الص وهذه
قسمه كبير منها خاصه قنابل ال- الجنرال
البربوس هذه متوفره بكثره من ايام الاتحاد
السوفيتي شكرا اللواء فايز الدويري في
عمان